i look back at my my college career and
unfortunately i had so many injuries
that i wasn't able to really focus on
the quarterback position the way that it
needs to be right because i was
rehabbing injury every year
and being in the nfl i haven't had to
deal with the injuries and i got to work
with drew and he brings in tom house he
brings in all these guys and man i'm
telling you drew just was like ah here
you go here's everything that's made me
great for so long and so i've just tried
to be a sponge and so to answer your
question i really
adopted all of his workout habits his
workout routine i started working with
tom house and um i really had time to
allocate to the position
that is taysom hill you may not have
recognized the voice peter king we were
joking at the super bowl before we had
taysom hill on the program we had no
idea what he's going to sound like like
we don't know anything about tasty meal
other than he is awesome at everything
he does any voice going gonna come out
of his head and i just said well i guess
that's taysom hill he's never done press
conference he's never done interviews i
know he talked to you at the super bowl
he talked to us we were in the same
general area and uh the guy's great he's
a phenomenal player he's not a jack of
all trades he's a master of all trades
he's been great for the saints he was
the best player on the field in the wild
card game between the saints and the
vikings several weeks ago and i think if
the saints had used him a little bit
more that game may have turned out
differently for the new orleans saints
great clip from paul allen the voice of
the vikings who says on a play where
drew brees is back in the game after
taysom hill had run rough shot over the
vikings defense paul allen says i can't
believe i'm saying this it's a relief
drew brees is back in the game that's
how good taysom hill is and there's that
run if you're watching on tv he was
phenomenal that day so we're mentioning
all of that peter because
you spoke with sean payton
and i get the impression number one
that they're going to apply a restricted
free agency tender to take some he'll
not sign him to a new contract and
number two
sean payton expects that somebody's
gonna sign taysom hill to an offer sheet
that if the saints don't match it would
give the saints a first round draft pick
mike the saints can't know what they're
going to do with taysom hill until they
know what drew brees is going to do and
the very simple reason and everybody
would say wait a second why
what possibly if
drew brees might only play one year
maybe two max more why would it matter
the saints should keep taysom hill well
obviously they should but
if they've got to throw out and let's
make up a number if they've got to throw
out 30 million for one more year of drew
brees let's just say
then they're going to be really hesitant
certainly they're not going to bring
teddy bridgewater back in that case
but certainly then they're not going to
say well you know we can match anything
on taysom hill
mike the only reason why i think this is
such a fascinating story
is that i have had
i'd say one team solidly interested in
another team sort of fishing that i've
talked to since the end of the season
where they are fascinated with taysom
hill
where they are interested in taysom hill
and not necessarily as an every down
quarterback but as the kind of weapon
that sean payton has unleashed on the
nfl so
i asked peyton at the super bowl it's on
my podcast this week i said do you think
we're gonna play it too we're going to
make an
okay good
so so but
when i asked him this question
notice if we're going to play it and are
we going to play it now if we are
listen to the pause
from sean payton
because this is not really a question
that he wants to be answering and i
i and he was fine with it really but i
think in an ideal world he doesn't want
to give anybody any hint
of what the saints are gonna do if they
make an offer on taysom hill
let's play
sean payton talking to peter king about
taysom hill
yeah i think someone's gonna make him an
offer but for the fan to understand this
you take tender him as a one the team
that makes the offer on him and signs
him to a contract understands that
they're going to give up their first
round pick if we don't match it
that's easier to do when you're one
is picked 22 23 24 25 we might very well
see a team in the second half of the
draft do that
okay that's sean payton with peter king
on the peter king podcast from super
bowl week it's funny 22 is the bills
they're not interested 23 is the
patriots 24 is the saints they won't be
signing taysom hill to an offer sheet as
a restricted free agent they would just
sign him 25 is the vikings um
look peter i agree with you that they
won't know what they can do with hill
until they know what brees is going to
do however i interpret everything he's
told you as meaning number one they're
not going to try to sign taysom hill to
a contract before they apply the rfa
tender number two they're going to apply
the first round tender number three they
anticipate someone signing them to an
offer sheet and number four they're
confident they'll be able to match it
right and they'll be able to say to
whoever signs them to the offer sheet
thank you for doing the work for us now
we have this guy signed for x number of
years and the reason i say that i
believe and i don't know this but i
believe based on all the threads that
are out there
that
they know what they're going to play pay
breeze if brees comes back it's just a
question of his breeze coming back the
money isn't the issue the money isn't in
doubt and it ain't going to be 30
million i think if brees comes back it's
going to be reduced salary reduced roll
because they want to use more taste some
hill i detected from what peyton told
you a confidence that they will have
hill in 2020 they're not going to have
him by signing him to a contract before
an rfa tender is applied and someone
would sign him to an offer sheet they're
going to have him after someone signs
them to an offer sheet and the saints
match it and i think they've already
committed to doing whatever they have to
do to keep this guy around that's my
interpretation of everything that's been
playing out
the strength in
if somebody makes him on offer and signs
him to a contract
the strength for new orleans is that
that team there's a chance that that
team would be signing him as a gadget
player not as a long-term quarterback
and mike can you imagine and let's just
make up a number let's say somebody
signs it taysom hill to a contract
that is three years
35 million
uh you know 15 million in the first year
and let's just say let's just say
and the saints
think to themselves
phew
i'll tell you in 2021 and 2022
we project taysom hill to be our
starting quarterback
so
we're gonna get him almost
for in those two years what a rookie
deal would be for a quarterback and it
won't exactly be that obviously it'll be
more than that but
that team might be doing the saints a
favor that's why this is such a
difficult
uh contract to project because if you're
only getting them as a gadget player i i
think max you'd be
like 10 million on the cap something
like that right i mean is there any way
i mean maybe you front load it because
you know the saints don't really have
the money to go crazy in the first year
of this deal maybe a front loaded hoping
that it's too rich you know for them to
uh you know for them to afford
but honestly mike the more i've thought
about this the more i say if i'm the
saints i'm hoping he gets an offer sheet
yeah but peter here's the thing if i'm
taysom hill and they offer me three
years 35 million dollars as a gadget
player i say stick it where the sun
don't shine sideways because i'll just
take the six million this year as as a
restricted free agent and become an
unrestricted free agent next year and
let somebody pay me to be a quarterback
i'm not taking a three-year commitment
to be the saints gadget player i want to
be a quarterback the saints view me as
the long-term franchise quarterback sean
payton has compared me to steve young i
want to get paid like steve young so
hale's got some control here if he's
willing to ultimately decline all offers
and play one more year for six million
which is still a hell of a lot more than
he ever thought he was going to make in
the nfl but it's a hell of a lot less
than he deserves here's my wrinkle that
i could see someone like bill belichick
trotting out peter a one-year offer
sheet like the patriots did with
emmanuel sanders several years ago when
he was an rfa with the steelers one year
and you throw in let's say you give him
15 million for one year and you throw in
a term no franchise tag no transition
tag for 2021 applies equally to both
teams doesn't get invalidated by the
management council it's a legal and
appropriate mechanism
you do that and the saints match it
you got a guy who's a free and clear
unrestricted free agent in 2021 and
anyone can sign him away from the saints
and that throws everything into disarray
for next year the only problem is if the
saints don't match it and take your
first round pick you've given up a first
round pick for one year with taysom hill
with no guarantee that he's going to be
your quarterback beyond 2020.
i mean it's all that's a pretty risky
thing plus
obviously maybe that's one of the
reasons why the patriots have
reportedly
said to tom brady we want to know what
you're going to do before
uh the league year starts
and and so then obviously then they
would be in position if brady goes to
make that sort of offer to take some
hill
my problem with it is very simple
that let's say that taysom hill is the
patriots quarterback
in 2020 which i absolutely could see
you know then
do you want to risk
taysom hill and josh mcdaniels making
beautiful music together this year
not being able to franchise them but
just thrown in the pool with every other
team then
there's a good chance in my opinion
that a team picket who's going to be
looking for a quarterback in 2021
maybe the bears i mean you'd pick a
number yeah minnesota there would be a
number of teams that will have money
then the patriots are going to have to
decide do we want to sign
a guy who's played quarterback in the
nfl for one year do we want to sign him
for 33 min three years 100 million
you know and
those are the problems i i knew what you
were going to say mike because i've
heard that floated and i've all i've
also heard it said
that you know by people in the league
that that would be even more dangerous
than any of the other options because if
he plays great
then you're gonna have to compete with
everybody to pay him at the top of the
quarterback market
so if i were the patriots
and i were doing this what i would do
because i would obviously if you're
going to sign taysom hill you would have
a quarterback opening
i would sign him for three years and
pick a number you know 60 million or
whatever it is
sign him for that right now
front load the
you know the thing so there's a lot in
the first year so that then the saints
probably wouldn't match because they
couldn't match and then you would have
your quarterback for the next three
years
there's one other wrinkle here that
would be completely unenforceable and
folks would get in trouble if they
actually did this but this is part of
life in the nfl it's driven by
relationships it's driven by who you
trust it's driven by who you know it's
driven by how well you can work together
with unofficial understandings that are
completely and totally unenforceable but
both sides would have to trust each
other for example
you do the one year offer with 15
million plus a commitment not to use the
franchise tag or the transition tag
after the 2020 season and at the same
time
you have an understanding as to what the
next contract will be
after 2020 and both sides agree now that
they will honor that and again it's
unenforceable it would get people in
trouble but it happens and if taysom
hill's agent jeff nally decides that
there's someone that he trusts in new
england and that person trusts him this
is a way to get hill paid it's a way to
get him maybe to a place where he would
want to be part of a culture that not
nothing against the saints at all
because this would be a tough call for
taysom hill but if the saints aren't
going to pay him voluntarily you get to
the point where you start looking for
who's who's willing to pay me what did
dwight schrute say i'm a very loyal
person and i'm willing to go to the
person to the company that values my
loyalty the most by giving the most
money for it i mean that that says a lot
about how you feel about a guy by how
much you're going to pay him so i just i
don't want to rule that out that there
could be a side deal a wink nod deal
that would be the new contract after
this one-year band-aid device that would
get hill out of new orleans if he wants
out
i mean i think it's all
what's incredible mike
if we just spent 20 minutes talking
about a backup quarterback for the new
orleans saints but we know he's going to
be a star
but peter here's why we did it you and i
both know this guy has star potential
this guy could be a lamar jackson type
of a player if and when someone allows
him to be the starting quarterback and
i'm convinced if the saints had used him
just a little bit more maybe they'd have
been in the super bowl against the uh
kansas city chief
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports